alright good afternoon everybody we are
now on our second portion of the program
today for the science research symposium
I'm David Buckwald I'm an associate
director for the office of undergraduate
admissions and I'm really just here to
get things started as a panel moderate
if you will but hopefully a lot of it
will be directed from from your
questions as your students are actually
meeting with faculty now and current
students especially in their departments
of interests over the next hour with the
chance to even visit some laboratories
depending on department we've found it
in the past particularly helpful for you
to connect with folks some of our
terrific faculty and administrators who
would work very closely with your
students should they matriculate and
choose to come to columbia and in
particular study the sciences here so
without much further ado I'd like to
start with Professor Christy book if
you'd introduce yourselves and then
we'll go down the line and begin with
some questions okay so my name is Nick
Christy blick that's a double-barreled
name with lots of hyphens I'm a token
faculty member on the panel and I'm a
nerd scientist and the two other hats I
wear which is why I'm sitting here is
I'm also in charge of an undergraduate
research program called the Robbie's
Scholars Program which includes students
from all scientific disciplines there
about 40 right now in the program and
the third hat is that I'm the chair of
frontiers of science which is the the
core curriculum class in the sciences
it's a new class starting in 2004 and
that that happens twice a year so I'm
going to also come from that perspective
anyway Nick Christy blick hello
everybody and welcome to Colombia my
name is neo O'Brien and I'm the director
of undergraduate career development and
I'll later talk about all those services
and resources but essentially we work
with students from the second they get
here to help them identify where their
interests are to connect them with
opportunities and with people in the
field and to really bring them or help
them to make informed decision
and reach fulfillment in their careers
and we also work with them as alumni
what Nev did mention is she's from the
center for career education my name is
Andrew plah i'm a senior assistant dean
and center for student advising the
center just so you know is located on
the fourth floor of this building the
way the center works every student is
assigned an advisor in the center for
student advising who hopefully will work
with them through all four years so one
of the things that every student has is
the resource of using our office from
the beginning even before they arrive
and throughout the time here good
afternoon everybody and welcome to
Colombia my name is Michael pittenger
and I'm the associate dean of fellowship
programs and study abroad our office has
a dual role in that we help students
with all aspects of applying for
national and international scholarships
both for while they're here and after
graduation and then we also work with
students and help them prepare to study
abroad so we do the study abroad
advising that your daughters and sons
might need as they prepare to go study
abroad we can talk more about what it's
like to be a scientist or a
mathematician or an engineer studying
abroad in a little bit so while you
think of some questions and you may have
I have I have a few I jotted down in
advance to kind of help get the
discussion going but I'll actually start
with Professor Christie look if i may
just kind of getting a sense of the the
faculty student relationship at columbia
what is your relationship like with your
students students in your department or
students who you might teacher mentor in
research okay so columbia is a small
place and there are just over a thousand
students per year in the college and
about a quarter in round numbers turned
out to be the sciences and many of those
are pre-made and so if you think about
250 students a year there are a lot of
faculty with whom those students can
interact so the
thing that Columbia can offer is a lot
of one-on-one attention to any student
who sees fit to go and find that
attention in the days when I was an
undergraduate which was a few years ago
the model was that you take classes and
then you get your bachelor's degree at
some point you might go on to a PhD now
the modern model certainly the Columbia
model is that we try and get students
involved in real science and so there
are opportunities for any student who
wishes to grab it to get involved in
research labs every department has its
own particular style of doing things and
so part of the relationship with
students is not only in in small classes
it's also in as one-on-one situations
where they are involved in a research
operation and they can start that as
early as their first summer for very
Kingston's I mean it's not something
that anybody is obliged to do but it's
an opportunity there so in terms of our
relationship with the students it's in
those two places it's one is in terms of
the classes but typically small classes
once you get beyond basic chemistry or
calculus and secondly it's in this sort
of situation where the students are
actually it part of the research
operation thank you Nev actually if i
may ask you a question as well maybe
we'll just kind of go down the panel
this way as a way to get started in
terms of advising students in their
possible career paths or if a student
may already know that they're very much
interested in the sciences and what
comes next what are the resources that
the center for career education provides
or that most undergraduates and the
sciences may utilize while they're here
and to echo professor Blix comments
about tailored advising we also work
one-on-one with the students to really
talk through what are the options
affiliated with their areas of interest
and also to connect them with an
experience so there's a very strong
research opportunities here on campus
but also we will work we have a science
technology engineering internship
program and we also work with employers
at all the National Labs we work with
employers in industry so we
internships and full-time opportunities
in the farmer and biomedical industry in
all of the Health Sciences in major
Institute's like Howard Hughes and and
it goes on and on I have lists here of
things that we do we also have domestic
and international internships we have
some science internships internationally
and and through that each student gets
an alumni mentor they get housing and
they get an opportunity to also have
that cultural immersion as well as this
science research opportunity as well and
so we work as I said counseling the
students we have many networking
opportunities we have a very active
alumni base and one of the benefits of
being in New York City many of our
alumni stay around and stay connected so
we have many events and programs to
connect students with people in the
field so while they're here they're also
talking to people about what a day in
the life looks like for a scientists and
these different organizations and also
about how to get in there so in a
nutshell it's canceling one-on-one it's
major programs career fairs our own
dedicated step internship program and
also alumni and professional networking
opportunities for the students thank you
thank you you've no I think that's very
helpful I'm Andrew in a similar way in
your office and through the center you
talk to little bit is in your
introduction about kind of student
advising but what does that experience
like I'm thinking especially the first
couple of years as well in terms of
course and major selection and how you
work one-on-one with with your students
um the center of student advisor with
our first content of contact is actually
often before the Act students arrive we
have some are advising sessions which
are large group sessions large being
about 20 to 30 students in them they are
both in New York and scattered at other
locations around the country the goal of
those sessions is to really give
students an overview of the curricula
so they're making more informed choices
when they're making their first course
selections when they arrive on campus
during New Student Orientation students
are obliged to meet with their csa
advisor the time is often limited 15 to
20 minutes so obviously the reason why
we had to summer advising sessions is so
we can get or get over the questions
about multiple requirements and focus on
things that are more particular but your
URL poor students to come back to see
their advisors we have regular walk-in
hours monday through thursday for an
hour to have two three to four plus
appointments you can make an appointment
to discuss whatever you want to discuss
forever however long you want to discuss
it some appointments might be 15 minutes
some half hour some over an hour the
when we the way we approach science
students is really not that much
different from the college except
sometimes there's pressures on science
students to take certain courses earlier
the students and the college don't
declare their major to their fourth
semester their sophomore year but
obviously if you plan the major in
physics chemistry or environmental
sciences or any of these Sciences you
often have to start taking course as
well before that so the are are one of
the challenges are one of the things we
want to discuss with the students it's
okay if you are aiming for one of these
Sciences which classes should you be
taking right now so that might be in
case of physics might be an intro
physics sequence calculus that she'll be
taking alongside with your first year
core requirements so it's the other
point we want to talk about is mallets
we don't want to be have people too
overwhelmed to try to figure out a
schedule that works with them and
doesn't actually hold them back from
achieving what they want to achieve
thank you Michael if I may ask a little
bit about prestigious fellowships for
those not as familiar things like the
roads or the Truman how do we go about
working with students and how do you and
your team work with students to prepare
for those competitive opportunities sure
we do a lot of outreach on campus first
and foremost with faculty encouraging
faculty to recommend students that they
think
qualified for national and international
fellowships we work with students from
all four years and our first
conversation with your student might be
about what their professional goals are
what their intellectual goals are what
their personal goals are what do they
want out of a fellowship and from that
conversation we start to generate ideas
we've had great success with students in
the sciences applying for national and
international fellowships the biggest
award for undergraduates and the
sciences is the Goldwater which helps
funds helps fund excuse me students who
are planning to go on and get a PhD in
science or mathematics but we've also
had great success with a number of other
fellowships such as the Fulbright which
would allow somebody to do independent
research overseas the gates Cambridge
which allows students to pursue a
masters or PhD Cambridge after they
graduated from Columbia as well as
things like the roads and the Marshall
what we do is we educate students about
how to apply and also about how to know
themselves and what their intellectual
interests are and what they want to do
in this case in the sciences so that
they can craft the best application
possible and we help them with all
aspects of that from working on research
proposals working with them on personal
statements on interview skills if we
need to and we work with them as much or
as little as we want but we do that in
conjunction with administrators around
campus as well as as faculty may I ask
if you can also just such a little bit
on study abroad or just I'll wear that
hat down for a second what we do is one
of the reasons that Columbia has paired
fellowships and study abroad in the same
office is because there's a tremendous
amount of overlap students who often
study abroad come back from that
experience and want to apply for a
fellowship that might allow them to get
back to that country in question or to
go somewhere else or to study here in
the States conversely we also have a
number of students who want to study
abroad but want to look for a fellowship
that would help fund that either first
semester or a year
or summer sessions that we work with
students and pass students back and
forth between staff and our office about
twenty-five percent of any given
Columbia class studies abroad the number
for science majors is pretty small and
we would like to see that number larger
quite frankly last year we had about 20
to 25 students so it's a pretty small
subset now part of that is because of
what Andrew mentioned earlier that for
science majors oftentimes they need to
be thinking about a sequence of courses
and that may make it more challenging
not impossible because we have a lot of
successful students who study all over
the world on study abroad who are in the
sciences and mathematics but most
students study during their junior year
usually it's in the spring of their
junior year but we also have students
who study abroad in the fall as well as
in the fall of their senior year so we
work with students to make sure in
conjunction again with with advising
staff in with faculty to make sure that
any student who wants to go abroad we
can give them the tool so that they can
study abroad and for many of them it's a
really life-changing it's which we can
talk more about another question
answered one of the things that's come
up more and more I think for Columbia
students as well as that they might
study abroad in what you might think of
is the non-traditional semester either
over the summer or in conjunction with
an internship where actually I was
thinking curricular lee for example
professor christie black you often teach
your class where you take everybody to
death death valley if i understand
correctly is that right oh yes we do
some wild things and those in rural
sciences but part of the trick in terms
of the study abroad is to manage the
curriculum and so in addition to the
advising Dean's which we've heard about
we encourage students who come anywhere
near us to talk to what's called the
director of undergraduate studies in the
department that's I'm one of them and
that that person then works with a
student to try and design a curriculum
of courses by certainly by the time we
become juniors to sit down with them and
actually have them map out their entire
remainder at Columbia and if they're
going abroad they really have to do that
because as you say they they get out of
cycle so we have to have some way of
very very cunningly integrating whatever
they're doing in with a curriculum so
that they don't miss anything and it's
entirely doable but it all comes down to
planning well you know we run wild
courses at outside Columbia campus and I
take students out in the desert in the
spring break and we manage that simply
by having it you know the actual trip
over spring break so there are ways of
doing it but we do send students to with
weird places and I would just add to
that it says something you said to every
wishes but Columbia is working very hard
to continue to develop new kinds of
study abroad programs that are what we
would consider non-traditional that
would be during the summer for shorter
periods of time that do allow scientists
to tap into both scientific interests as
well as other interests we can talk
about some of those as well but it's one
of the the really exciting things about
working at Columbia right now at least
with regard to study abroad is that we
are looking for those kinds of
innovative ways to make a students
undergraduate liberal arts education a
more global one transitioning just a
little bit from from what you were
saying Michael and from Professor crew
see Blake I think there's no shortage of
ambition among Columbia students in
terms of their goals individually and so
I think you know becomes more and more
of a challenge as they want to fit more
and more into their four years and I
always talked about within context
there's a lot of room for everything
it's just a lot of our students want to
do many different things this idea of
more than one major or wanting to fit in
lots and lots of electives and so things
can be done but at a certain point we
really want you to graduate in four
years so for a student there is there
are certain trade offs or a lot of
planning that's involved I mean speaking
of that kind of transitioning a little
bit professor Christy book as a student
how do students go about finding
especially for the sciences I imagine
this very important to you but finding
and pursuing research opportunities and
just a sense of what's available ok so
that's that's the common question
and the simple answer is networking what
you do if you're a student is that you
you're in classes so the class
immediately means that you have contact
with a particular member of the faculty
and there may be a teaching assistant or
several teaching assistants in the class
so they are also contacts if you have
some inkling of what you're interested
in you can show up in the department and
you can talk to the DUS or you can go to
seminars in the department or you can
just corner other undergraduates who are
sophomores or juniors who've had
experiences or you can corner graduate
students or you can go on the web and
you can google all the fact that faculty
members in a certain discipline and find
out what they're doing in a way that you
couldn't win house them to graduate so
there are lots of avenues and what you
do is you simply pursue them and you
don't get put off because somebody
doesn't answer the email or it doesn't
have an opportunity for you keep
assuming them and the reality is that if
you are bright-eyed bushy-tailed young
student and most of the Columbia seeds
are then you will find opportunities and
networking is the way you do it and all
the students either work with they
they've seen to find their way seem to
find a pathway it isn't an issue and
when the faculty-student ratio is as
favorable as it is and bearing a mind
that the lots of other people besides
faculty in my institution there are 200
PhDs in other science and it's not just
faculty so lots of opportunities to find
out you know activities they can get
involved in and I believe some students
even do research for all four years
while they're here right yeah we like to
get them and we like to get the best
students picked early so one of the the
roles of the thing I do in the spring
with first-year students is to try and
identify students who look like they're
really good and we try and get them we
try to pick them up early so not this
last summer the summer before I had
three interns in the summer and two of
them were first year students and we got
them into into our intern program and
pay them stipend and gave them housing
and in fact all three students that year
went to a major national meeting and
presented posters so they not only did
research for the first time they took
their research on the road they rode
abstracts they got my got a public
they went on the road by themselves I
wasn't there they presented their
posters of the major national meeting
professional scientists in Oregon and
that's entirely doable in one summer
they were very sharply did her well we
gave them some help of course but when
the idea was to get them going and one
of them has just completely gone off
scale now she's applied for a great many
different fellowships and she's been
extremely effective she's on a complete
different trajectory she's now a junior
she's clearly going into a major ph.d
program and she's fabulous and one of
the other students in that group she's
writing a manuscript that came out of a
summer project for a major journal she
will be the first author she's currently
a senior so the idea is to get them on a
trajectory and and help them develop
because when they start of course
they're very smart but they know nothing
but you get them started and then you
kind of nurture them and you know some
subset you know they'll they'll keep
going similarly i nev what kind of
internships or more specifically for
scientists have recent scientists been
been pursuing or any examples you have
of kind of how you support current
scientists with opportunities well as i
mentioned and i am again will work with
all the National Labs Brookhaven will be
here on Friday with 130 because actually
one of our very busy weeks it's we
called engineering week but that's
engineering in science so we have 135
employers here actually downstairs on
Friday many of those looking for
scientists but we've students in all the
lads so Howard Hughes all the university
also Institute's affiliated with health
so any of the Cancer Research Institute
the labs I have lists of labs and sorry
they're not off the top of my head but
also internships in Johnson & Johnson in
clone a lot of the students who want to
go into industry will come to us mark
will be here all of the pharmaceutical
companies also we call the consumer
packaged goods so students a lot of
scientists will go into lore'l or
no nor Procter & Gamble work for
palmolive and things like that so we
would put students into all of those but
we also I wanted to highlight just one
student who went did our Columbia
experience overseas Hong Kong and with a
blog she wrote a blog on our website she
was in neuroscience student and she
interned with an organization working on
epilepsy but what she said on her and
it's on the websites you can go search
it's under our Hong Kong blog for CEO
and it she said being able to learn more
about epilepsy has made me even more
excited to go into the quickly
developing field of neuroscience so one
of the things we do is work with
students wherever they are and that is i
don't know what i want to do with this
i'm doing chemistry i've no clue to
really expand their options and talk
about not only the resources on campus
but also the employers were working with
the opportunities to network with people
in the field and so if there we do meet
many students who may not know exactly
what they want and we will tailor our
work with them along the way so that
they're identifying the resources and
creating plans for themselves based on
their interests and other got examples I
printed so much for myself that it's
it's probably too much and D show
research a la scientific instrument I go
on and on because we deal with thousands
of employers and so and many many signs
employers will come to columbia for the
stellar students so it really depends on
the subject the student is learning and
their interests and we will then direct
them to the resources affiliated with
those interests and also just to
piggyback in what everyone else is
saying we help them through the
application process we help them be
competitive because often students will
be stellar in their potential but then
they won't go through with the the work
to really apply themselves and create
competitive applications for these
research and other industry
opportunities so we work with them in
that as well and we've many I brought
samples of some of our materials that
help students to really prepare
themselves for the world of work
irrespective of what buddies and I was
just said I was I bumped into a student
who actually is a tour guide with our
office but computer scientist and Google
was meeting at noon in the computer
science department recruiting I even
took a quick picture of the Google
assigned past back to our officers
because it's just neat that they're
meeting specifically with folks you know
about job opportunities so oh yeah we
research in motion Boeing thurs and
every employer is i would say target in
columbia and we're working with them to
help them figure out how to reach the
students as well so we work both with
the employers to target students and
also with the students so that they can
match themselves with the employers
thank you Nev Andrew if I may ask to
maybe a little bit outside the academic
scope how the center for student
advising works with students on the
personal side managing everything and
how you support students as kind of
their growing as college students into
adults this is kind of a change of pace
by the way I describe the center of
student advising is we're like the tip
of an iceberg there's a lot of advising
resources were the visible on since our
names attached the student every student
has an advisor every in their academic
profile we are listed next to them but
there are a lot of other resources out
there and one of our roles we play is to
connect the students to the resources
available to them we get students who
are some know exactly what they want to
do and they're very self-motivated
others a little bit lost some of the
advice might be how do you make a
connection with a faculty member in
order to find out about a research
opportunity so one of the things we
might encourage them is to not use email
actually show up to the office hours
face-to-face contact is always better
it's a lot easier to have a long
conversation that way then you can do /
email / weeks but some of the people
with students we deal with are also
dealing with other issues
that could be medical it could be
psychological could be other things like
just dealing the transition of moving
from high school to college so part of
our role is also the connect them to the
resources that are available counseling
and psychological services are in this
building there may be issues but they're
roommates we might talk to them about
talking to their RA are the residential
program directors of the 80s to talk
about may get some kind of mediation
involved there there are a lot of a
number of issues that students face and
sound like we have the answers Fred most
of them but what we can do is direct
them to the resources that are available
to them sometimes its academic questions
like connecting to study abroad
sometimes it's might be career oriented
questions or connecting them to the
Center for career education but all the
things our life issues that we try to
connect them to the available resources
here the key thing to remember is this
wide net that's available to them and
it's just not the limited to our office
I think we call it now the community of
advisers that a student might have well
they're here notable folks across the
spectrum as you're seeing how about
questions from the audience questions
that you may have is we wrote good hands
are starting to go right out yes
the me I'll repeat back the questions
that everybody asks that we all here and
we understand if I understand correctly
your question was about study abroad
opportunities and about how they're
funded are they funded I think you had a
specific example about a program that we
have with Oxbridge we have some we have
lots of programs but that happens to be
I think a pretty popular one so sure
I'll take that in two parts with regard
to the Oxbridge program one of the
largest study abroad programs that
Columbia students take advantage of is
our special relationship that we have
with both Oxford and Cambridge we have
set up over the years a number of
agreements with different colleges in
both universities which allows our
students to directly enroll for the year
and as a result it's a very competitive
program because we have many students
who want to go study at one of those two
schools with regard to study abroad and
how students pay for it whether it's
that Oxford program or a program
provided by another university students
pay the same tuition they would pay here
at Columbia so their financial aid is
portable during the school year it's
exactly the same as if they were here on
campus that's because they're getting
Columbia credits at the end of that
process and so there's no difference in
what happens with the tuition overseas
in here
yes students often win scholarships that
they've been applied towards additional
study abroad experiences so for instance
we've had a number of winners over the
years when a grant called the NSE p
Boren grant and that's sponsored by the
US government and it allows people
intensive language study during the
summer or during a semester long program
they take that scholarship money with
them and it applies towards those
programs there are a couple of things
that financial aid does that include a
work exemption portion of your financial
aid package so that you can apply for
additional grant money for example for
non a non-paid internship or research
opportunity as well as for study abroad
so little things that do help some
departments have some I believe prizes
or grants also for summer study
depending on the department some of
those are in the sciences some in other
departments but that also can help
offset some cost but again as Michael
was saying that it would never cost more
for your student to go abroad than it
would be to be here for a semester and
we want that opportunity should that be
of interest to your student to be
available for every single undergraduate
here that's one of the commitments that
we do have it's good comparison to that
so one of the things that students do
when they want to get a summer
opportunities that they apply to our
called re you programs research
operatives with integrators and research
experience one of the greatest and the
Kombi has a lot of those on its campus
but they're also many in other campuses
so they apply to this and those
typically have a stye pendant hasn't
attached them but there are also
opportunities overseas and some of our
students in a final way to to Britain or
Switzerland or you know other places
where they will apply competitively for
one of these these programs and if they
get into those programs of course those
programs will also pay so that there's
no guarantee that there's a competitive
but on the other hand it is not patootie
and some students have found their way
them and some of the scenes i work with
scenes know about those and family and
that's something we work with students
on their planning and how they're going
to fund their experiences and so we have
workshops around how to fund your
internship another experience we have
resources online resources with all the
columbia related funding opportunities
be they threw institutes or through our
office and and also other national
opportunities to fund that experience so
we try to get students again as early as
possible to think about what do you want
to do and how are you going to pay for
it so that both they're applying because
there might be different applications
questions yes sir is there any
difference between the college in the
engineering school in terms of what's
available on the whole it's very similar
in terms of how advising support may
work i think there's differences in the
curriculum they can make I think study
abroad in the case of going abroad I
think a bit more challenging I don't
know if professor Christy black or
anybody else wants ants or any other
either curricular or extracurricular
differences but yeah I think the big
probably the biggest single difference
is that the engineering school has more
stipulation requirements of course they
had to take so it in terms of managing
all their math physics chemistry set
rates it's a bit more challenging to
squeeze that in I my suspicion is that
actually a smaller group then the
college goes abroad is that true yes
that is correct and engineering has
their own special office of global
initiatives because one of the things
that they're trying to do right now is
to work out relationships with partner
universities overseas that would allow
engineering students to continue taking
that very set sequence of courses
overseas so they are looking into that
to try and increase those numbers as
well and sorry I just want to give an
example and the engineers without
borders and they do fundraising all year
they work with faculty on amazing
projects internationally so again the
students who's interested the
engineering student who's interested in
going abroad there are resources on
campus
on campus and professors who will work
with them to bring them those
opportunities and they also do
fundraising to to help pay for them he
recognizes another complexity and that
is the half the plant is in the southern
hemisphere and because the half the
plant is in the southern hemisphere
means the summer is winter and winter is
summer and the terms are all different
so in terms of how students actually
manage it it's entirely doable but it's
this it's some interesting because you
have to make sure that they mesh with
the terms as they're defined by some
University in New Zealand which are not
the same as our terms I know you just
add actually if for folks you either you
know the engineering school supports
undergraduate engineering students and
then the pure science is rooted in the
college those two schools are very much
integrated in terms of the undergraduate
student experience where students live
and where they are and even some of the
clubs like Neve mentioned engineers
without borders you can be a scientist
involved in that organization scientists
and engineers for a better society is a
very popular undergraduate group and
they do work together there are also a
lot of other specific science-based
undergraduate groups outside of the the
formal academic experience undergraduate
science journals just a lot of
additional opportunities for students to
support their interest to publish
promote showcase their research and and
such other questions
so two questions just one about advisor
to student ratios which are going to
sound a little bit different than
faculty student ratios if I'm a manager
expectations briefly although we're very
competitive among our peer institutions
and that's improved a lot but Oh Andrew
talk about that and then the second
question was about frontiers of science
and that being a course that all of our
college students take including our
students who do plan to major in science
and so maybe Andrew to start and then
professor because you look our ratios
are in flux because we haven't hired our
full staff one of the things that also
you should know is there a special
endowment to call the quickly endowment
I think it's changed its name though
since then that is to incur one of the
goals was to improve the advising one of
the things I'd led to us the
construction of the fourth floor center
but also the hire more staff so we
haven't reached full capacity our
current ratios are approximately about 3
20 / advisor now that may seem high
until you start breaking it down if you
think about 80 students 60 to 80
first-year students coming in would be
meeting with one advisor you'll find
that the the needs of students very
especially also despite vary by year I
would see often YC as first-year student
Mike I might see that student very
frequently then they get more
comfortable in terms of their major they
choose their major they reach out to
their faculty advisor that I might see
them very periodically and so the
advising relationship will vary
depending on the needs of the student
some means I see on a weekly basis some
I see once a semester or once a year
depends on what their needs are and the
ones i don't see doesn't mean they're at
any kind of trouble often they're
sailing along doing everything you're
making all the connections they want to
make their with career education they're
going to the michael about fellowship or
their connecting with their faculty it
will vary that way okay what in
particular do you want to hear about
frontiers of science
okay so so there's a core curriculum and
the main reason why any student comes to
Columbia is to get an education we're
not into training people so the
frontiers of science is the same way
frontiers of science is not about
training scientists frontiers of science
is about exposing everybody to the
nation of what the scientific method is
and how you might apply to solving real
problems and how you get a real sense of
what science is about because the
typical exposure of a high school
student of science is very much about
rote learning of facts many of which
were established in the 19th century and
the idea of frontiers as well it's at
the frontier it's where we have a
combination of lectures which happen on
Monday mornings and then seminars in
small groups 20 20 students on a Tuesday
through Thursday scheduled meeting for
two hours and they're normally there are
four themes and a term and the themes
chosen to intersect with the interests
of students but they are chosen also to
illustrate how science functions and
they're typically topics which are not
dealt with in high school science so
this term we started off with the brain
so basic neuroscience we're in the
middle of astronomy now we're going to
go on to a unit on earth science and we
wind up and biodiversity and all of
those are actually different from what
the student would normally exposed to
now dave was saying well they're the
courses for science students as well it
most certainly is and in my section half
my section science students some of them
hotshot heart science student so I get
saddled with them and they're fabulous
but the goal is that you are trying to
communicate something which even though
they're very sharp they may not in fact
I've internalized at all about what
science is really about and the other
part of it is that you are exposing them
to much broader range of issues than
they would have met in the typical
science course so if they take an AP
this and AP that you're still going to
show them a lot of new stuff and it's
done as though you know in a manageable
level but the goal is to expose them to
a lot
new things and with the expectation that
some of them who who absolutely know
what they want to do will this discover
perhaps they don't I started off as a
physics major and I wound up in earth
science I remember we had a very smart
young lady a few years back who told me
when she first arrived that she was
definitely going to go to physics I
thought that's great but you know Olivia
you should explore things you should you
should you know look at other
possibilities because it maybe you'll
discover something that you don't know
about you oh no no no I know I want to
do physics I can tell you in six weeks I
saw her again six weeks later she was
then a an environmental biology student
so far six weeks to go from absolutely
this is what I want to do to something
completely different and this is not
making a statement that's good or bad
it's making a statement that the lots of
options and what we try to do is to
expose them to many of their options
which they don't know about they don't
know how exciting something might be
because they know nothing about it even
one of our full faculty professor
Virginia Cornish and the chemistry
department is a Columbia College alum
and she talks about how when she came
think she wanted to focus on political
science but discovered chemistry through
some of the first classes she took so
that's very much something we want to
happen but you know in the broad sense
of possibly supporting your students and
the sciences and I just wanted to add
that one of the things that we excel at
is helping the students to be
comfortable with uncertainty we don't
want them to know they don't have to
know the minute they get here about
everything and we want them to make
informed decisions so often the ones who
knew who know and and blinker themselves
you know we see them as alumni looking
for career changes so we like the
weather here explore as much as possible
think about what you're doing what does
that mean for where your next step is
going to be and that constant reflection
and learning is what we we aim for and
there are some students and your student
might be like this you truly know what
they want to do we very much have those
students and can support them right away
to which is you know one of the
beautiful things of a research
institution yes sir
good question let me just repeat it real
quick depending on how advanced your
student might be talking specifically
about AP exam or maybe international
baccalaureate or British a level
programs if you have done sir certainly
very well at the high school level and
science how does that work in terms of
placement how we support a student
curricular Lee at the beginning okay so
the answer that is it normally works
through departments so if it was ap
chemistry then it would be up to the
chemistry department it would be up to
the the director of undergraduate
studies and in some cases you simply say
well you've got an AP 5 and calculus bc
that then implies that you will do this
it'll imply what course you go into in
the physics department I believe we have
a physics faculty member here that there
are there are placement tests where the
student arrives in the fall and says I'm
a hotshot this and the student is asked
to take a little exam to find out just
how hot shot they really are and so
you're using these tools to plug them in
to the right level you're certainly not
wanting to waste their time on stuff
that they already know and the AP the
way the AP credit works is that he
doesn't mean they don't have a
requirement it means they simply plug in
at a different level and we're going to
celebrate the fact they've they've
gotten that ap five in calculus okay
let's go to the bank let's take you to
the next level right so that's the way
it works in practice
it's a great question question was if
your student has multiple interests in
the sciences or their interests might
like the cross section me what we call
the interdisciplinary sciences very good
question how we would support them in
those interests both in the classroom
and outside the classroom I think the
best answer is that they simply explore
I mean they just take take a course in
something which they think really
interests them and just see how it goes
and be willing to the side at the end of
that wow that was great or mmm so much
sort o or absolutely not you know you
get a sense of whether at the college
level that's what you want to do but the
only way to find out is just to kind of
get stuck into it the same would be true
of research experiences way you try
something out you go and spend the
summer in a chemistry lab and then you
decide that this is absolutely what you
want to do or perhaps you decide maybe
not so much but even when you decide
maybe not so much that's really good
because now you've said I wanna try that
out and that's not really where I want
to be and a lot of things of that nature
but experimenting is really what you
know they should be encouraged to do and
with a bit of luck it all crystallizes
and by time they've become sophomores
and juniors they've got it figured out I
would just add to that that there are
there are 22 science majors in the
college and some of them are actually
quite interdisciplinary like mathematics
computer science is a joint major we
have faculty who you know in computer
science are doing code writing with
linguistics faculty and our newest
building is the interdisciplinary
science building that's going up which
is really about the cross section of a
lot of what's happening environmental
chemistry that's like a joint major of
sorts I guess in terms of they might be
housed in a particular department but
with lots of classes that might cross
register meet students interests so
that's you know with a lot of our
students they also very different
interests like Professor valentini was
talking about they might be a earth and
environmental scientist or a physicist
who also wants to do music or dance or
something like economics and we have
lots of the students at Columbia and
that we can support them I think across
those those areas in the back
question was about teaching load and how
teaching load is supported across the
faculty and sense of kind of students in
classes maybe class size if that's also
something you were asking about yeah I'm
not sure I quite understand the question
yeah talking about the faculty
responsibility or the oh that you just
mean it's pretty spread out and it's
it's it is spread out in frontiers of
science we have some of the best
teachers in the university some of the
most active researchers and university
we had a Nobel laureate in the course
until recently so we've got people who
are absolutely top of the top of their
game they're teaching you know one of
the most basic courses in the university
because they believe in it so it's not
the case that all the introductory
courses are taught by instructors and
all the specialized courses by senior
faculty it's a real mishmash in terms of
how that's done I would just want to add
to that and in terms of the students
that our office works with who are
applying for things like the Rhodes
Scholarship I worked this year with a
student who his first year of being here
through a little bit of perseverance and
asking around and talking to advisors
found himself in a Nobel Prize winners
lab and worked there immediately and
learned a tremendous amount from him
I've worked with a number of students
over the years who have been with
faculty that taught them in one of those
I'll put this in quotation marks lower
level courses they've gone on to do
research with them published with them I
am always amazed even though I work here
every day at the level of that kind of
relationship between the faculty and our
students and
way the students are able to generate
opportunities so that faculty and
faculty go way out of their way to
generate opportunities for their
students and advocate for them so I
think that that's a pretty remarkable
thing that's going on here I agree with
that too I think a couple questions over
here yes sir
that's that's a fantastic question just
about how we prepare students for
postgraduate opportunities so possibly
the PA cheese to come but also med
school or say they go on another path
professionally business school law
school as as part of the Center for
student advising there's a
pre-professional office that advises
lost students who want to go to law
school or to med school the
pre-professional office for medical
school is a very embrace of process it's
a very extensive process one of the
things they do is the student presents
what they call up what they call it a
pack i'm not going to go into the
acronym but it's almost like a mock
makeup of what do it have to do for when
they are actually apply and they use
this to have interviews with the
students and then write an extensive
letter covering them including
incorporating not only their personal
history here but also highlighting their
letters of recommendation so every
student applies to medical school from
columbia and this also goes for alumni
as well because I'm that some of the
students have come back you know they do
a post back and then they will go
through Columbia will get that letter if
they're doing the process through us I
don't know what institution your son or
daughter was that who dis applied but
that's the process at Columbia for
graduate school we rely very heavily on
the faculty and I think professor blue
should talk about this because
essentially it's a lot different game
and I'll pass it over to him yes well
for graduate application zits it is
typically the students who've been
involved in the research operation so
you get to know them one-on-one and
there are many elements to a graduate
school application but certainly the
personal statements a key one way you
can imagine writing a very mature
personal statement which indicates that
you really have the
tool the intellectual tools that like to
make your reticle candidate and then you
also have the benefit of having somebody
on the faculty who knows you very well
then can can write a really strong
letter not a pro forma letter but a
letter that has lots of meat in it and
so there is no I'm not aware of sort of
formal programs for helping students
apply but it's like that it's the one on
one attention they get that enables them
to do so and certainly in my department
something like a third to a half of our
students go on to PhD programs and know
the way they do that is is by in part by
osmosis and in part by you know getting
one-on-one guidance they say well I know
I'm interested in doing a thesis on this
kind of area we know where would I go to
do that well I I'll give you you know
here's some names of people who are
really very good in this particular
discipline these are the people you
should contact so it's it's done at that
level not in terms of a whole program
and I would say and then I'll turn to
Michael because we all touch on this so
in our office we have a graduate school
series and really where are where we
work with students is really helping
them to evaluate their decision to go to
graduate school and so we have a series
we're bringing a lot of people from
admissions to talk about what speaks to
them in application materials how to
prepare as you're going through from
first year on to build those
relationships to think about the
experiences that will enhance an
application and then we also rely on the
faculty would direct students to the
faculty to really talk about and their
interests and the programs that would be
best for them around the country and
internationally and our program we also
talked about funding opportunities but
we do that in partnership with the
Fellowship's office now hand it over to
Michael well I would just add we have a
number of students who are applying for
fellowships that would fund medical
school or PhD in the sciences so every
year we have a number of winners who in
national science foundation grants we
don't measure our success if you've on
our website you'll see all of the
different winners we've got on different
fellowships but in our mission statement
we as an office are very clear
columbia are very clear that were not
about a body count of numbers who's one
how many fellowships but rather the fact
that our students are more sophisticated
at the end of the process so that they
are able to successfully be persuasive
in a graduate school application or a
professional school application is very
important to us and to that end when
we're advising someone about a
fellowship opportunity we're also giving
them the skills to know how to ask for
that letter of recommendation to know
what fellowship might be most
appropriate for what graduate program
have you talked to the faculty at that
school have you done the publishing that
you need to to be successful if we've
given them those tools then that's the
best the best kind of advising that we
can do
you
uh in Hampshire from again nothing's
mandatory Columbia so we have a
graduating student survey about well
this year its up but and I don't have
the results right now for this year
because it's still ongoing but generally
about thirty percent of the graduating
class go on to graduate school and they
would be a lot of the premier schools
around the country and that's right away
so more problems and then yeah we also
because again we work with alumni so
students may work for two to three years
and then say want to talk to you about I
really want to go back to grad school
can you help me with this decision sir
what percentage go to medical school I
can answer yeah if you are okay yeah do
you feel yeah sure just from
presentations with your with your
officer we're pretty in tune on the the
most recent statistics and it does seem
to keep getting better and better just a
couple of statistics in terms of sheer
volume you're talking about a couple
hundred students I believe but that
includes a couple of students who might
be recent alums they did teach for
america before applying to medical
school who I think successfully go on
per class to medical school but a good
portion of those students actually go on
for what our PhD MD programs joint
programs and so our acceptance rates for
us medical schools tends to be edging
towards that ninety percent and one of
the things that they asked us to
contextualize is that we do not limit
where students apply and our students
can really apply and we support them
wherever they do so that can further
contextualize why that figure is not
even necessarily higher per se it's
pretty good and we're the number one
feeder school for a lot of very
prestigious places including Columbia
Medical Center in their first year
medical school class the md/phd rate is
as high as i believe ninety-one percent
if i remember correctly and that's
something like we're talking a few dozen
students to from that rate so it's not
an insignificant number in terms of your
students and how that relates
particularly to the sciences is that
helpful sir so the right way to think
about this is not
so much in what Columbia does because we
are really reflecting the quality of the
students who come to columbia it really
becomes you know what an individual
student is able to do they they
certainly have all the support they need
in order to do it but ultimately comes
down to what the student him or herself
is able to do a few more quite a serious
gentleman in the very back do we give
credit for undergraduate research how
many credits maximum credit okay so
there are mechanisms by which student
can an undergraduate credit it almost
isn't needed because well Columbia
students a sort of off scale when they
want to take courses and we are forever
to try and persuade them into the view
that they shouldn't take quite as many
causes as they take they should spend
more time on the corset so in terms of
getting to 124 credits they need to
graduate I I do not perceive that any
student actually needs the research
credits in order to graduate that said
they can get research credits on the
other hand you're not allowed to double
dip so if you are being paid a stipend
to do a research project then you cannot
also get credit for it and that's a very
strict rule and many students prefer
yeah if they have the opportunity to be
paid a stipend that's right credits also
aren't the issue is what professor
gritsky black was saying students
actually have a lot of freedom within
reason if I may I don't know if you want
to touch on that Andrew in terms of how
they shop around or choose their
schedule they do up to a point first two
weeks you have to get adults sale
individual research is often added a
little late because they usually have to
line up their agreement with the
professor concern forms signs that might
be the third or fourth week when they
can it actually add it to their schedule
there is no limit in terms of the credit
that's applied to the overall graduation
credit 124 you need to graduate so but
there is a limit to some departments on
how many individual research credit will
count towards that particular major for
example psychology has a limit
not sure about Earth in environmental
science but they there's no limit again
so they still have students will do
excess research than they need for their
major but they will they want to do it
so they do it and they get their credit
that will count towards their overall
degree and will be on their transcript
what I've discovered I've been at
Columbia for 28 years what I discovered
is that most students who are in the
business of having these kinds of
experiences they just simply don't
either I don't even recall it because
most the students who are doing such
things they've already off scale in
terms of the number of courses they're
taking their already way beyond
graduating many of them have everything
they need by the end of their junior
year to graduate that level if they're
that keen and so it simply isn't an
issue and nobody asks about it nobody
worries about it because they just get
on with it and they have the experience
and that's you know if you think about a
scientist similar the an engineer if
you're talking about undergrads here at
Columbia they take more credits as they
might take laboratory courses they do
more in their time and so they end up
just kind of naturally having more
credits they're also particularly
ambitious again as what we were saying
earlier and want to do lots of things so
in terms of credits I I would imagine
for most students you advise Andrew but
I don't want to I don't want to answer
that question incorrectly but most
students it's not a credit issue in
terms of how they finish up is that um
that's generally true i mean like has
been said of first off you get AP credit
that would count you can count up to i
think the 16 AP credit can be counted
towards you degree students generally
the average which you have to take you
if you average it out with no AP credit
is 15 and a half the semester but
they're allowed to roll up to 22 and we
have an odd number of students who do in
roll up to 22 so they're often as
Professor Blake has already pointed out
a number of students who have an excess
of credit by the time they reach their
end of the junior year and so a lot of
this is just more to be added to their
to their transcript we have time for
just a couple last questions if we may
yes
that's so the question was the
percentage of freshmen involved in a
research lab let me just quickly before
cuz i don't know if anybody has a figure
like that off the top of our heads I
don't we encourage and allow our
students to really go for things right
away whether it's an internship or you
know research opportunities but I don't
actually know if any of our offices
formally track other than what you might
know anecdotally in your department
there are some programs that some
students at time of admission have the
opportunity to do research for all four
years for sure it's it's a guarantee of
sorts and for some of those students
they hit the ground running and can do
research right away but most of our
scientists it's really I guess up to
them and how they network is yeah i mean
the problem is we hear a first to assume
you don't yet know very much so you
obviously less competitive than say a
junior or senior and so it's not not
quite so easy as you have more
experience of getting in there and on
the other hand i found that students
were really keen well they seem to find
their way so try to come up with a
percentage it may not be a terribly
useful figure because then it's somehow
it's saying well these students don't
have opportunities but i know for a fact
that students who really very able then
do the rabi program that i run is
designed to give students were
hand-picked admission they don't even
know about it when they apply we just
pick up and tell it say we're going to
give you the scholarship and that gives
them the opportunity beginning in the
first summer to do research and and in
fact a small subset will actually do
research before they even arrived at
columbia it's not only a couple of those
students per year and some of those will
also do research on that first academic
year that we don't push them to do that
so there's a whole range of
possibilities here and there's no
requirement means some students in our
department do a senior thesis and do a
project in the end of their junior year
and that's fine too it's not like
they're being forced into doing
something is simply a matter of whether
the opportunities exist and the
opportunities exist depending on how
interested or how keen the particular
student is so a typical scientist who
wants to do research right away is
likely to probably be able to make those
connections and have those opportunities
on well know usually once they start I
mean before they come in with
be hard because most students aren't
coming from right around here to have
that opportunity that that that happens
to be a particular example but the ideas
as a first-year student if you wanted to
get involved in research the
opportunities are available for you it's
up to you to show a little bit of
initiative but with the same initiative
a lot of students take to get into a
place like Columbia that opportunity
often will be self initiated and often
quite successful question over here
it's great that you say that because
what we do the first thing when someone
says you this is what I want that's it
will say fabulous and what do you know
about that field and who have you spoken
to in that field and have you any
experience in that field and we'll try
to get them to engage a little bit more
and then if they still absolutely want
fabulous but we will usually just
questioned that and we all communicate
with the students so you know a student
can blinker themselves but there's many
connections and so you can encourage
your student just reach out and have a
chat about your med school options with
the med school advisor or something like
that and and those questions will be
asked